fue una ceremonia sencilla para el
hombre a menudo descrito como la brújula
moral de sudáfrica el famoso y modesto
arzobispo desmond tutú antes de morir
pidió el ataúd más barato y no quiso
ningún gasto suntuoso para su funeral en
la catedral de san jorge' de ciudad del
cabo al que asistieron sus amigos y
familiares más cercanos su viuda no mal
y solía se vistió de púrpura el color de
la túnica clerical de su difunto marido
el presidente sudafricano sin ramaphosa
elogió tú tú como un cruzado en la lucha
por la libertad la justicia la igualdad
y la paz
desmond tutu
hes vino a morar campas el arzobispo
desmond tutu ha sido nuestra brújula
moral pero también nuestra conciencia
nacional y bina after the adventure of
democracy incluso después del
advenimiento de la democracia no dudó en
llamar la atención a menudo con dureza
sobre nuestras deficiencias como líderes
del estado democrático leaders for the
democratic state
desmond tutu fue nombrado arzobispo en
1986 utilizó su posición para defender
las sanciones internacionales contra el
apartheid y más tarde para presionar por
los derechos a nivel mundial lo hizo con
humor auto despectivo y una risa famosa
y contagiosa ostentando gran cantidad de
admiradores de éste nelson mandela hasta
el dalai lama y desmond no estaba en una
cruzada de engrandecimiento personal o
egoísmo aunque a menudo y con desarme
admitió que amaba ser amado y que hay de
malo en ello acaso no nos gusta a todos
ser amados es un anhelo humano desde el
momento en que nacemos nuevamente álbum
después de unas semanas de homenajes las
cenizas de tutu descansarán por siempre
detrás del púlpito de la catedral donde
una vez predico su visión de una nación
arcoiris en la que todos los
sudafricanos pudieran vivir en armonía